merci de votre présence à cette table
ronde sur l'isolation des bâtiments donc
nous vous recevons aujourd'hui au titre
de vos cinq organisations
professionnelles qui regroupent des
acteurs de l'isolation thermique des
bâtiments le Syndicat national des
fabricants d'isolants en laine minérale
manufacturé représenté par sa présidence
Elisabeth Bardet qui rassemble les
industriels français fabricant de laine
de verre et de roche le collectif
isolant la terre contre le CO2
représenté par son porte-parole Monsieur
Olivier servant qui regroupe les
entreprises fournisseurs de solutions
destinées à réduire la consommation
d'énergie dans le bâtiment l'association
promotoir représentée par son président
Monsieur André dot qui regroupe 7
entreprises industrielle spécialisée
dans la fabrication de matériaux de
construction pour la toiture
l'association mur mentaux représentée
par son président Monsieur Philippe
Bousmar qui regroupe les industriels de
l'isolation thermique par l'extérieur
enfin l'association française des
industries de matériaux et composants
pour la construction représentée par
Monsieur Jean-Christophe Barban
directeur des affaires publiques qui
regroupent les syndicats et fédérations
qui représentent les industriels
fabricants de produits entrants dans la
construction madame messieurs vous
représentez à vous cinq l'industrie de
l'isolation acteurs indispensables de la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments il
nous est naturellement par une
nécessaire dans le cadre des travaux de
notre commission d'enquête d'associer
les acteurs de la filière
alors que l'objectif de notre commission
d'enquête et de comprendre les freins à
l'efficacité des politiques publiques en
matière de rénovation énergétique cette
table ronde vise notamment à
identifier de potentiels blocages dans
l'offre de rénovation la filière de
l'isolation des bâtiments est-elle en
mesure de répondre aux demandes de
rénovation énergétique si ce n'est pas
le cas comment l'expliquez-vous
s'agit-il par exemple d'une pénurie de
matériaux ou bien d'un manque de
qualification ou bien des deux peut-être
surtout alors que l'Europe à travers une
nouvelle directive sur la performance
énergétique des bâtiments semble vouloir
accélérer la décarbonation à l'horizon
2030 et que de fait ma prime rénove a
essentiellement financé des changements
de mode de chauffage n'y a-t-il pas un
risque que la décarbonation prenne le
pas sur les objectifs de sobriété et
d'isolation même si la rénovation
globale d'un logement reste l'idéal
beaucoup s'interrogent aujourd'hui sur
sa faisabilité sur la capacité de la
filière à faire face à une hausse
brutale de la demande et la collectivité
et les particuliers à les financer
plusieurs s'interrogent également sur la
pérennité des matériaux employés lors
d'audition précédente certains ont parlé
de vin à 25 ans de durée de vie ce qui
voudrait dire que l'isolation réalisée
aujourd'hui serait à refaire en 2050
est-ce exact selon vous
de plus alors que le confort d'été n'est
selon nous pas assez prise en compte
est-ce que certains matériaux
d'isolation ne sont pas mal adaptées à
l'évolution climatique qui nécessitera
d'être au moins autant protégé du froid
que des vagues de chaleur enfin le but
de la rénovation énergétique étant tout
autant de protéger le pouvoir d'achat
que la planète les matériaux d'isolation
peuvent-ils eux-mêmes relever le défi de
la neutralité carbone de la
recyclabilité ou du réemploi voilà avant
de vous laisser la parole pour répondre
à ses premières questions qui sont déjà
très vastes et pour un propos
introductif que vous partagerez alors
dans l'ordre que vous le souhaitez et
pour le temps qui vous semble le plus
opérationnel sachant qu'on a l'audition
après on a une heure et demie c'est ça
donc une heure trois quarts de consacré
donc je pense qu'on a quand même
suffisamment de temps pour pour échanger
et puis surtout ensuite pour que
monsieur le rapporteur puisse vous poser
un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires par rapport à vos propos
introductifs ainsi que d'autres membres
de la commission d'enquête je vous
indique que cette audition est diffusée
en direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat qu'elle fera l'objet
d'un compte-rendu qui sera bien
évidemment publié je place également
vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête serait
passive des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal
qui peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende aussi je vous
invite donc les uns après les autres à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je ne jure on peut commencer
par vous monsieur barbant
je vous remercie de vous prêter à ce
formalisme qui fait partie aussi de
toutes les commissions d'enquêtes donc
je vous laisse la parole bien volontiers
et ensuite monsieur le rapporteur et
d'autres membres de la commission
viendront vous compléter vos propos et
donc rajouter un certain nombre de
questions supplémentaires je ne sais pas
est-ce qu'on commence par madame la
Présidente Bardet peut-être messieurs
voilà allez on vous laisse commencer
madame
merci beaucoup
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie d'avoir convié le film Le
Syndicat national des fabricants
d'isolants en laine minérale
manufacturée a participé à ce débat le
film rassemble et représente 5
entreprises adhérentes les sociétés
eurocoustiques isovaires knaufinsulation
recoule et URSA soit plus de 90% de la
laine minérale vendue en France ces
industriels comptent 8 sites de
production en France pour environ 3000
emplois directs répartis sur l'ensemble
du territoire
sur les quatre dernières années près de
400 millions d'euros d'investissements
productifs ont été opérés par ces
industriels et d'autres sont en cours
nous estimons que les ventes d'isolants
en laine de verre et en laine de roche
permettent d'isoler chaque année environ
un million de maisons
et 98% de ces isolants sont produits
localement
les laines minérales sont une filière
d'avenir au cœur du quotidien des
Français ce sont les isolants les plus
utilisés en raison de leur performance
thermique acoustiques de protection
contre le feu également de leur coût
optimisé
l'isolation en laine minérale c'est une
solution économique et écologique
c'est une industrie moteur des
territoires qui recrutent et qui forment
la filière offre des emplois qualifiés
non délocalisables notre industrie fait
appel à de nombreux savoir-faire et
irriguent l'ensemble du secteur de la
construction enfin c'est une industrie
engagée dans le développement durable la
décarbonation de ces activités
l'optimisation environnementale avec en
particulier l'électrification de ces
procédés de fabrication la récupération
de la chaleur fatale et l'intégration de
matière recyclées
il y a entre 50% et 80% de contenus
recyclés dans nos isolants
nous saluons la prise de conscience
politique sur la question de la
rénovation énergétique l'isolation des
bâtiments est un levier principal de
sobriété énergétique la rénovation de
l'ensemble du parc au niveau équivalent
Bâtiment Basse Consommation BBC à 2050
permettrait entre 400 et 500 TW
d'économies d'énergie par an cet environ
1,2 fois la production nucléaire
annuelle
les défis sont immenses près de 6
millions de ménages sont en précarité
énergétique 700
000 rénovations globale et performante
doivent être opérés par an entre
2030 et 2050 pourtant malgré des
objectifs ambitieux et des avancées
réglementaires la rénovation du parc
n'avance qu'à petit pas
nous pensons que la rénovation
énergétique globale est par étape doit
être une priorité nationale car elle
permet la réduction des consommations
énergétiques la réduction des factures
énergétiques et la décarbonation
notre filière est prête pour accompagner
la massification de la rénovation
thermique globale et nous appelons au
renforcement et au rééquilibrage des
dispositifs d'incitation à la rénovation
thermique en fait à l'isolation pour
réduire efficacement la consommation
d'énergie en France le dispositif des
C2E des certificats d'économie d'énergie
et le premier levier de financement
c'est un dispositif décidé par l'État
assumer financièrement par les obliger
il faut augmenter l'enveloppe et la
valeur des C2E isolation précarité il
faut rééquilibrer le marché en faveur de
l'isolation car aujourd'hui il ne se
concentre que sur le changement des
équipements enfin il faut établir un
corridor de prix
pour stabiliser le dispositif sur un
temps long
le dispositif ma prime rénove est
également clé
l'augmentation des Audes ma prime rénove
en avril l'année dernière 2022 pour le
changement des systèmes de chauffage
pour remplacer des chaudières gaz et au
fioul ne suffit pas un bâtiment mal
isolé reste une passoire thermique
l'efficacité de la lutte contre ces
passoires thermiques commencent par un
rééquilibrage des aides les gestes
d'isolation ne représentaient en effet
que 21% en 20221% des aides publiques en
2022 alors qu'il consiste constitue
excusez moi 4 des 6 types de travaux de
rénovation à réaliser dans le cadre
d'une rénovation performante
alors que les objectifs de rénovation
énergétique sont constamment réaffirmées
la filière appelle le gouvernement à
prendre
urgemment les mesures correctives
nécessaires et à stabiliser le
dispositif pour tenir les ambitions les
critères d'éligibilité des aides à la
rénovation doivent être alignés et
simplifier pour améliorer leur
efficacité la lisibilité et
l'accessibilité des travaux de
rénovation pour les particuliers
nous appelons par ailleurs à une vision
et une action d'ensemble plutôt que
d'opposer les matériaux les isolants en
l'occurrence
le basculement vers le tout biosourcer
est un pari risqué à l'heure où cette
industrie ne dispose pas des outils
productifs suffisants pour répondre à la
demande la politique doit s'appuyer sur
deux jambes complémentaires les isolants
minéraux et les biosourcés à ce titre
les laines minérales sont les alliés
naturels de la construction bois en
raison de la protection qu'elle confère
en matière de risque incendie et
d'isolation thermique et acoustique les
entreprises de la filière minérale
investissent massivement et
régulièrement c'est lourds
investissements nécessitent visibilité
et stabilité face à la concurrence
européenne l'enjeu est de maintenir la
capacité à s'approvisionner en matériaux
made in France
performant et accessible à tous les
portefeuilles
la filière rappelle donc à garantir des
conditions de concurrence équitables
entre matériaux fondés sur une approche
performantcielle scientifiquement valide
et non sur des choix de matériaux a
priori
alors que les objectifs climatiques sont
appelés à être renforcés aux échelons
nationales et européens la mixité des
produits de construction est une mesure
de bon sens s'inscrivant dans une double
logique économique et écologique madame
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
messieurs les sénateurs pardon mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je vous
remercie pour votre écoute et je suis
toute disposée à répondre à vos
questions
merci madame la Présidente qui veut
prendre la suite de madame la Présidente
allez monsieur Barban
voilà madame les présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs donc Jean-Christophe Barban
donc je suis directeur des affaires
publiques de l'association imcc qui
regroupe l'ensemble des fabricants de
produits de construction produits
équipement de construction je suis
également délégué permanent du comité
stratégique de filière industrie pour la
construction et donc si vous me le
permettez j'intervien j'interviendrai
aussi à ce titre voilà juste pour vous
rappeler que la imcc regroupe toutes les
organisations professionnelles de
producteurs de matériaux de construction
7000 entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
450 000 collaborateurs 45 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires sur le
marché français
sur tous les matériaux intervenants dans
la construction de l'acier du bois du
ciment du verre de la terre cuite des
plastiques peinture et chimie du
bâtiment isolants minéraux et biosourcés
produits d'étanchéité produisent
équipement électrique équipement de
chauffage climatisation ventilation
voilà le rôle de la imcc du CSF
IPC c'est de mener des actions
collectives qui sont complémentaires des
actions individuelles menées par les
entreprises
notamment sur les grandes priorités de
la transition écologique de la filière
qui sont la décarbonation des procédés
de fabrication des produits et des
ouvrages le développement de l'économie
circulaire en particulier recyclage
réemploi et enfin la rénovation
énergétique performante des bâtiments où
les industriels peuvent jouer un rôle
clé en collaboration avec les autres
acteurs de la filière qui sont
importants aussi distributeurs
entreprises de construction maître
d'oeuvre maître d'ouvrage
ce rôle clé donc
il le joue non seulement comme fabricant
de produits d'isolation mais aussi de
ventilation de chauffage de
climatisation ce que je disais tout à
l'heure et aussi d'instruments de
contrôle de ces équipements qui sont
importants
les industriels innovent en permanence
pour accroître la performance de ces
produits tout en minimisant leur impact
environnemental
les caractéristiques environnementales
et sanitaires de ces produits ainsi que
leurs performances techniques
performance mécaniques performance
d'isolation durabilité
sont consignés dans ce que nous appelons
les fiches des fiches de déclaration
environnementale FDES pour les produits
pète pour les équipements fiches qui
sont mises à disposition de l'ensemble
des acteurs de la construction au
travers de la baziniesse ce qui permet
aux acteurs de la construction munis de
ces fiches de performance et de
caractéristiques environnementales
d'optimiser au mieux
leur ouvrage d'un point de vue technique
et environnemental que cet ouvrage soit
de construction neuve ou de rénovation
bien entendu
aujourd'hui nous pouvons déjà dresser
deux constats
concernant la rénovation énergétique
premièrement même si les innovations
sont permanentes notamment en matière de
décarbonation les solutions techniques
existent
pour rénover de façon performante
l'ensemble de tous les bâtiments et
toutes les catégories de bâtiments et
les capacités de production sont là pour
servir les objectifs quantitatifs de la
France en la matière
deuxième constat les industriels que
disaient madame Bardet tout à l'heure
demande que les produits pas que les
industriels l'ensemble des
professionnels de la construction
demandent que les produits soient
appréciés objectivement sur leur
performances
techniques et environnementales
performance qui sont d'ailleurs
vérifiées
et communiquer régulièrement je lisais
tout à l'heure à travers la baziniesse
cette approche
performantcielle permet au marché de
choisir librement entre les produits
sans discrimination en tenant compte
aussi de leurs critères économiques
coûts et disponibilité bien sûr
la question majeure qui se pose à nous
aujourd'hui en matière de rénovation et
la massification ça a été dit tout à
l'heure de
des rénovations pour pour tendre vers
l'objectif de 500 000 rénovations par an
jusqu'en 2050 et nous en sommes loin
nous le savons
je rappellerai rapidement les enjeux de
cette rénovation
réduction des besoins en capacité enfin
réduction bien entendu des émissions de
gaz des fesses un effet de serre
réduction et consommation énergétiques
mais aussi réduction des besoins en
capacité de production d'énergie
électrique
bon 10% de la rénovation du parc
permettrait d'économiser cette nouvelle
tranche nucléaire ce qui n'est pas rien
des enjeux sanitaires bien entendu à
travers l'amélioration de la qualité de
l'air intérieur conditions de travail
dans les bâtiments des enjeux sociaux
bien évidemment et puis des enjeux
économiques avec la création d'activités
d'emplois très nombreux dans la
rénovation compensant la baisse à long
terme de la construction neuve on sait
que dans les années qui viennent la
construction d'un va baisser de façon
très importante et donc la rénovation
peut prendre le relais au travers des
mêmes acteurs
et bien entendu création d'emplois dans
nos industries puisque les produits de
construction se transportant mal sont en
grande majorité fabriquées en France
pour servir le marché français
dans ce contexte
un certain nombre de points clés nous
semblent à mettre en avant concernant
les politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation pour relever le défi de la
massification le premier défi a déjà été
dit c'est de cibler les rénovations
globales et performantes je ne reviens
pas là-dessus ça a été suffisamment
expliqué je crois que c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez très bien
le deuxième défi qui nous semble très
important c'est l'accompagnement des
maîtres d'ouvrage dans l'acte de
rénovation un accompagnement plus
efficace
pour accompagner que ce soit les
collectivités territoriales ou les
maîtres d'ouvrages privés du logement ou
des bâtiments tertiaires dans leurs
opérations de rénovation cela exige des
diagnostics fiables mais aussi des
exécutions professionnelles
qui sont aujourd'hui
un vrai défi
l'acte de radiation est encore trop vécu
comme une punition par les maîtres
d'ouvrage ce qui n'est pas sain ce qui
n'est pas positif ces sources
d'incertitude ces sources d'anxiété très
souvent
ce qui fait que les maîtres d'ouvrage
reportent leur décision de rénover
il faut donc rassurer ces maîtres
d'ouvrage leur apporter aussi
la pluie nécessaire dans les diagnostics
dans la réalisation des plans dans le
choix des prestataires dans l'obtention
des financements
troisième défi qui nous semble important
le défi financier il a été suffisamment
déjà développé je n'y reviens pas
quatrième défi l'accroissement de
l'offre professionnelle de rénovation en
commençant par les capacités
diagnostiques et d'audit mais aussi de
réalisation des travaux avec des
entreprises au groupement d'entreprises
en mesure de gérer efficacement les
interfaces entre les différents lots de
la rénovation et une main d'oeuvre
qualifiée nouvelle qui doit être
renforcée par de nouvelles formations
mises en place dans les territoires
notamment au profit des jeunes qui sont
en général enthousiastes lorsqu'il
s'agit de mettre en œuvre des travaux de
rénovation qui sont utiles pour la
société
enfin le dernier défi qui nous semble
extrêmement important c'est l'implique
l'implication forte des collectivités
territoriales plus forte qu'aujourd'hui
dans le projet de rénovation énergétique
de notre pays
les régions d'abord qui sont non
seulement intéressés en tant que maître
d'ouvrage de certains bâtiments publics
mais aussi pour renforcer
l'accompagnement des autres maîtres
d'ouvrage dans les territoires avec une
véritable ingénierie de rénovation
qu'elles sont capables de mettre en
oeuvre adapté au terrain et aux
typologies des bâtiments mais aussi pour
apporter des financements
complémentaires et enfin pour développer
des formations adaptées aux besoins
croissants de compétences en la matière
les départements en Suisse et enfin les
communes et les intercommunalités qui
sont organisées et dimensionnés pour
porter et mettre en œuvre
opérationnellement des projets ambitieux
de rénovation énergétique
cette application forte des
collectivités territoriales et le sens
du projet rénovatif et porté par le CSF
IPC projet qui est actuellement soumis à
la pression de l'État et très
prochainement des régions de France
rénovatis suggère une approche
territoriale via des projets pilotes
concernant le bâtiment public et le bâti
privé porté par les intercommunalités
dorénobatti les régions en vocation à
réunir et structuré avec le csfipc
l'ensemble des acteurs de la filière
régionale de rénovation et de lancer en
accord avec l'état des appels à
manifestation d'intérêt pour appuyer les
intercommunalités dans le montage de
leurs projets
alors côté les acteurs de la filière
notamment les industriels présents
régionalement peuvent apporter leur
expertise et leur solution
en matière de rénovation et aussi de
décarbonation du bâtiment voilà ce
projet est encore le finalisation avec
les équipes de l'État et j'ai payé en
particulier et avec certaines régions
qui sont déjà s'expriment déjà et
fortement intéressé par ce projet voilà
je vous remercie pour votre écoute merci
Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
président du Groupement du mur mentaux
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur madame et messieurs les
sénateurs merci tout d'abord de nous
avoir convié à cette audition et de
pouvoir ainsi contribuer aux travaux de
aux travaux de votre commission
notre association puisque il en est
ainsi le groupement du murmonto est une
association qui regroupe en fait les
industriels de l'isolation thermique par
l'extérieur et dont l'ambition la
mission je dirais est de contribuer à la
rénovation énergétique et de réussir la
transition énergétique de notre pays
cette association est composée de
d'industriels et de membres qui
composent les systèmes d'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur nous sommes
des acteurs de l'enveloppe du bâtiment
et nos membres nos 30 membres qui
représentent à peu près 95% du marché
sont ou bien des grands groupes des TPE
des PME ou des ETI qui sont tous
implantés localement et engager fort
ement donc dans les territoires avec des
emplois qui en effet ne sont pas
délocalisables et qui sont tous engagés
dans et bien la décarbonation également
de leur process de production
un système d'isolation thermique par
l'extérieur vous allez me permettre
d'être un petit peu factuel mais
simplement pour vous expliquer ce que
c'est c'est un isolant que l'on vient
imposer sur la structure d'un bâtiment
qui va également protéger la structure
de ce bâtiment cet isolant quel qu'il
soit d'accord va être recouvert de
différents composants et ensuite du
décoration esthétique qui va permettre
et bien de raconter une histoire de
façade alors ce système d'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur qu'est-ce
qu'il va vous apporter et bien si on
pense avant tout aux occupants il va
avant tout apporter du confort du
confort d'été vous en parliez je pense
que vous avez tout à fait intérêt et
raison de mentionner ceci du confort
d'été et du confort d'hiver parce que
aujourd'hui et bien pour tous nos
concitoyens il est fondamental d'habiter
dans des bonnes conditions sanitaires
dans des logements décents donc déjà
c'est du confort le deuxième point bien
entendu c'est va sobriété énergétique et
je veux véritablement mentionner ce
point parce que dans les temps que nous
connaissons et bien on sait bien que
sobriété énergétique égale souveraineté
énergétique et cette sobriété
énergétique va donc rapporter à aux
occupants qu'ils soient maître d'ouvrage
public ou qu'il soit maître d'ouvrage
privé une baisse des dépenses donc une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
notamment pour nos concitoyens dans les
temps que nous vivons et également bien
entendu derrière une baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
d'une baisse émission de CO2
ce que ça va apporter aussi c'est tous
les bénéfices causanitaires donc je nous
trouvons au sein de notre association
que nous ne parlons pas assez dont nous
ne parlons pas assez pardon parce que on
sait bien aujourd'hui 1 euro investi
dans la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments c'est 42 centimes d'euros
d'économiser en frais de santé c'est une
étude de l'OMS qui a été reprise par
l'OMS récemment sur
ces chiffres là et qui montre bien à
quel à quelle hauteur se trouve
l'importance de la rénovation
énergétique pour la santé de nos
concitoyens notre organisation elle se
mobilise au niveau européen et vous en
avez parlé madame la Présidente dans le
cadre de la rénovation d'un révision
pardon de la directive européenne sur la
performance énergétique des bâtiments
avec les trilogues qui vont commencer
dès le 6 juin d'ailleurs mais elle se
mobilise également en France et nous
avons publié deux livres blancs sur la
qualité de l'enveloppe du bâtiment dont
le dernier en mars 202 3 qui s'appelait
pas de qui s'appelle pas de neutralité
carbone sans une isolation globale et
performante des bâtiments dans ce
document nous appelions à des mesures à
des mesures phares pour atteindre la
stratégie nationale back carbone les
objectifs que le gouvernement a fixé
dans la stratégie nationale ba carbone
25 ans le premier la première mesure
c'est quelque chose que vous connaissez
puisque ça a été demandé également par
un des sénateurs c'était un plan choc
d'éradication des passoires thermiques
aujourd'hui nous estimons que il y a un
saupoudrage des aides au niveau de ce
qui est à la disposition des pouvoirs
publics et qu'il suffit qu'il est
nécessaire maintenant de se concentrer
sur des sujets pour massifier les effets
et les impacts positifs donc nous avons
proposé et nous sommes appuyés pour le
financement sur une étude qui a été
réalisée par un collectif que vous avez
auditionné ici le clair avec
l'initiative rénovon qui a réalisé en
2021 une étude complète sur et bien les
coûts et les bénéfices d'un plan de
rénovation des panneaux des passoires
énergétiques en 10 ans et on parlera
après du montant je pense parce que
c'est quelque chose qui est intéressant
donc c'était la première mesure la
deuxième mesure et vous en avez
également parlé la rénovation globale et
performante à un coût elle est
quelquefois difficile à réaliser et en
fait nous avons souhaité dans ce dans ce
livre blanc et bien proposé la mise en
place d'une prime de travaux combinés
qui va faciliter la programmation de
travaux de geste simple permettant
d'atteindre le niveau BBC en deux ou
trois étapes et certainement trois
étapes ce qui est bien préférable
le niveau BBC c'est l'objectif de la
SNBC 250 ce sont les quasiment il y a à
peu près 30 millions de logements
aujourd'hui si j'enlève les logements
vacances j'enlève les résidences
secondaires si on veut atteindre le
niveau il y a quasiment entre 27 et 28
millions de logements à rénover d'ici 25
ans donc ça veut dire que c'est un point
qui est essentiel et puis enfin le
dernier point sur lequel nous appelons
véritablement les pouvoirs publics à
réfléchir c'est d'arrêter de considérer
la rénovation énergétique comme une
ligne budgétaire dans le budget de
l'État la rénovation énergétique est un
investissement il faut considérer la
rénovation énergétique non pas comme une
dépense qui va s'additionner d'année en
année et qui ne pourra absolument pas je
dirais être reporté d'un d'une année sur
l'autre d'une mandature sur l'autre la
rénovation énergétique doit être un
investissement au bénéfice de la planète
au bénéfice de futurs de nos du futur de
nos enfants et c'est pour ça que nous
considérons qu'aujourd'hui il faut
travailler sur le financement le tiers
financement il faut travailler avec les
banques de façon à ce que les chiffres
de la rénovation énergétique
ne fassent plus peur mais qu'il fasse
envie voilà je serai tout à fait disposé
à répondre à vos questions
merci je suis président de promo toi
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci d'abord pour cette
invitation que nous prenons de façon un
peu égoïste au sein de promotoir comme
une reconnaissance de la filière et du
toit dans dans les enjeux de rénovation
énergétique et je rappelle vous le savez
forcément ça a dû vous être dit que 30 %
de la déperdition énergétique se fait se
fait par le toit
alors rapidement l'association promo toi
c'est quoi vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente c'est une association créée
en 2005 qui on comprend cette entreprise
industrielle et d'iliance Isover
céréales unilain VELUX VMZ et winner
burger qui qui sont spécialisés dans la
fabrication en France de matériaux de
construction pour la toiture et là on
parle pas uniquement de l'innovation de
l'isolation on parle de de couverture
parle de zinc évidemment on parle de
panneaux solaires et on parle de fenêtre
de toit pourquoi elle a été créée pour
essayer de nourrir le débat avec les
acteurs du bâtiment d'une part mais
aussi avec les institutionnels comme
comme vous en particulier autour du rôle
du toit dans les enjeux d'environnement
on y est tout à fait dans le sujet
aujourd'hui mais aussi de logements et
d'urbanisme j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure qui nous paraît extrêmement
important quand on parle
d'artificialisation des sols à ce titre
nous publions régulièrement des études
comme comme vous des livres blancs le
dernier nous concernant ça a été fait en
2022 et ça parlait du toit au coeur des
enjeux sociétaux alors pour nous le toit
et on y reviendra car c'est le sujet
vraiment du jour c'est on l'appelle dans
notre jargon la cinquième façade c'est
cette coque protectrice contre le froid
et contre le chaud comme vous l'avez dit
c'est évidemment le support idéal de
captage de d'énergie solaire aujourd'hui
et demain mais c'est aussi un créateur
d'espace habitable sans consommation
foncière
et que nous jugeons aujourd'hui
sous-exploité
d'une manière générale ça a été dit par
Madame Bardet moins de 25% de la
totalité des gestes et des par ma prime
rénov en 2022 on concernait des travaux
sur l'enveloppe et une part négligeable
sur le sur le toit
il nous paraît fondamental ça a été dit
par mes trois collègues et je pense
qu'Olivier servant va y revenir il nous
paraît fondamental et c'est pour ça que
je le répète de créer une dynamique vers
la rénovation globale un favorisant la
rénovation performante par étape en
créant des parcours complets de
rénovation énergétique dans lequel nous
l'espérons la rénovation de la toiture
aura toute sa place
à cet égard des aménagements à la fois
simples et concrets au regard des aides
au ménages permettrait d'adresser
le sujet qui nous dans notre domaine
nous paraît fondamental qui est le sujet
des maisons individuelles les maisons
individuelles c'est à peu près si
j'arrondis les chiffres 20 millions de
maisons individuelles en France un tiers
avec des combles aménagés un tiers avec
des combles aménageables un tiers avec
des combles non aménageables je je
simplifie sur le sujet des maisons avec
combles aménagées qui bénéficient
aujourd'hui d'un des plus faibles
niveaux d'aide
on a aujourd'hui une couverture pour les
ménages les plus modestes d'un maximum
de 30% des couteaux pour de l'isolation
par l'intérieur
dans les combles aménagés et qui tombent
à moins de 15% pour de l'isolation par
l'extérieur pourquoi parce qu'au
contraire des murs des parois verticales
ou on a des barèmes différents selon
qu'il s'agisse de d'isolation par
l'intérieur ou isolation par l'extérieur
c'est un dispositif qui n'existe pas
pour les toits c'est assez facile nous
semble-t-il à adresser évidemment en
trouvant les financements qui
correspondent à tout ça mais je rappelle
que dans les maisons à combles aménagées
on a estimé à 1,3 millions le nombre de
passoires thermiques
d'autre part les maisons avaient
aménageables là aussi encore une fois un
tiers du marché total des maisons
individuelles
nous considérons et ça va bien au-delà
du toit ça c'est valable aussi pour un
garage ou une pièce inutilisée qu'à
ménager des logements dans le périmètre
du bâti existant et trouver un vrai
levier fondamental pour la revue de la
rénovation énergétique et contre
l'artificialisation des sols des
millions de mètres carrés rapidement
activables nous concernant concernant
les toits on a estimé à 90 millions de
mètres carrés le gisement potentiel
activable
or le simple fait de créer des nouvelles
pièces exclut ses travaux de certaines
dispositifs de financement comme les éco
PTZ et ça aussi nous pensons que c'est
un point qu'on pourrait assez facilement
et assez rapidement adressé et dans le
cadre des maisons à combles aménageables
nous avons estimé avec les études que
nous avons initié à environ 400 000
passoire thermique le gisement
voilà je suis à votre disposition pour
répondre à d'autres questions
merci monsieur le Président à notre
dernier intervenant pour l'heure donc
c'est Monsieur servant porte-parole du
collectif isolons la terre
bien merci beaucoup merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs merci encore une fois de nous
autoriser à participer à ce débat et à
contribuer à l'enquête concernant donc
les politiques publiques de la
rénovation énergétique au titre du
collectif isolantaire contre le CO2 dont
je suis le porte-parole le collectif
isolant la terre contre le CO2 est un
collectif d'industriels acteurs leader
de du gros œuvre ainsi que du second
œuvre aussi bien en matière de parois
opaque de paroi vitrée et industriel de
la ventilation qui a été créée en 2003
en décembre 2003 au moment du débat
national sur les énergies au cours
duquel le Premier ministre de l'époque
Jean-Pierre Raffarin avait exprimé
l'objectif national de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'un
niveau équivalent à 4 à 5 d'une division
par 4 à 5 des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre du parc de bâtiments existants
à horizon 20 monte dans la lignée et
dans la suite de la signature du
protocole de Kyoto qui entrait en
vigueur le collectif isolant la terre
contre le CO2 regroupe comme je vous le
disais des industriels leaders de leur
secteur et donc on y retrouve par ordre
alphabétique la société Aldes
eurocoustique hirs
lafargeolsim pamwilding placoplatre
Saint-Gobain glace unilain et VELUX ces
sociétés représentent à elle seule des
industriels qui fabriquent en France une
grande diversité très complémentaire de
solutions en faveur de la décarbonation
du bâtiment la sobriété énergétique
l'amélioration du confort la réduction
de la précarité
énergétique et
globalement la réduction des
consommations énergétiques des bâtiments
en travaillant en premier lieu sur la
sobriété énergétique
depuis 2003 le collectif isolant la
terre s'est astreint a contribué
activement par l'intermédiaire de
l'ensemble de ses membres à contribuer
au débat public et à la montée en
expertise technique de l'ensemble des
acteurs publics et privés autour de la
construction durable et de la rénovation
énergétique et alors qu'aujourd'hui la
consommation des bâtiments représente
encore 43% de la consommation nationale
et 23% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre les causes développées et le
travail d'expertise développé par le
collectif isolant la terre
ont toute leur ampleur prennent toutes
leurs ampleur avec donc un besoin de
continuer à développer des politiques
ambitieuses et à accompagner les
filières pour pouvoir déployer ses
meilleures pratiques de construction
durable et pour aujourd'hui bien
évidemment en priorité de rénovation
énergétique on sait que au rythme actuel
de construction lorsque l'on sera en
2050 plus de 80% du parc existant est
déjà construit et donc l'enjeu majeur
aujourd'hui en matière de réduction des
consommations de gaz à des consommations
d'énergie et des missions de gaz à effet
de serre est évidemment pour les
bâtiments de rénover à la fois
massivement et de manière très
performante le parc existant
comme le disait tout à l'heure l'un de
mes prédécesseurs dans ce tour de table
on a aujourd'hui
pour objectif d'amener le parc de
bâtiment à un niveau bâtiment basse
consommation en 2050
cela s'est traduit par une inscription
progressive dans différents textes dont
la stratégie nationale ba carbone et à
lui seul cet objectif conduit à la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
pour pouvoir réaliser un équivalent de
rénovation globale et performante de
bâtiments existants à hauteur d'un
équivalent d'environ 700 000 logements
par an et le moins que nous puissions
dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
loin du compte sinon nous ne serions pas
autour de cette table aussi belle
souhaite elle
la stratégie bac carbone s'appuie sur
trois grands piliers le premier grand
pilier c'est un pilier basé sur la
sobriété énergétique ce pilier vise à
amplifier massivement les efforts de
rénovation énergétique pour amener le
bâtiment à ce niveau bâtiment basse
consommation en moyenne en 2050 il est
complété de deux autres piliers qui est
un pilier de recours massif et
systématique aux équipements
énergétiques ayant les meilleurs
rendements du marché et un troisième
pilier lié à la décarbonation qui est
donc un pilier poussant à remplacer le
plus rapidement possible les énergies
fossiles par des énergies bas carbone
renouvelables ou électrique à ce titre
là donc la combinaison de ces trois
piliers est indispensable pour pouvoir
tenir l'objectif de 2050 et ça a de
nouveau été rappelé par le Haut Conseil
pour le climat dans un rapport récent
publié en novembre 2020
en particulier si on prend seulement le
premier de ces trois piliers la
rénovation énergétique du parc de
bâtiments existants au niveau bâtiment
basse consommation à lui seul ce pilier
permettrait d'économiser en termes de
consommation d'énergie un volume de
consommation d'énergie supérieure à la
production annuelle d'électricité
nucléaire en France donc ce premier
pilier est extrêmement significatif et
c'est dans ce cadre que s'inscrivent les
actions de l'ensemble des membres du
collectif ils ont la terre contre le CO2
par ailleurs la réduction des
consommations d'énergie du parc existant
et en particulier la réduction de la
consommation de chauffage qui représente
70% de la consommation d'énergie du parc
de bâtiments existants c'est aussi grâce
à des efforts d'isolation des parois
opaques et des parois vitrées une
occasion de réduire limiter fortement
les appels de puissance sur le réseau
limiter fortement et stabiliser les
commandes la demande d'énergie appliquée
au réseau et sur les centrales de
production d'énergie si l'on prend par
exemple l'appel de puissance d'une
passoire énergétique lors d'un pic de
froid il est deux fois supérieur à
l'appel de puissance énergétique d'un
logement construit dans les années 2000
et il est 4 fois supérieur à l'appel de
puissance énergétique d'un bâtiment à
basse consommation donc la rénovation en
travaillant en premier lieu sur la
sobriété énergétique grâce à l'isolation
de l'enveloppe c'est d'une part une
réduction des consommations d'énergie
d'autre part et ça a été rappelé une
amélioration significative du confort et
des qualités sanitaires des bâtiments
c'est une action pérenne de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
des bâtiments et c'est aussi une une
meilleure capacité à gérer les réseaux
et en particulier le réseau électrique
en matière de production et en matière
d'investissement dans le transport et la
distribution
alors c'est dans cette perspective que
nous avons fait historiquement un
certain nombre de contributions au
niveau du collectif isolant la terre une
des actions notoir du collectif isolant
de la Terre a été de créer avec le
concours des régions de France en
particulier le collectif est énergie que
vous connaissez et que vous avez eu
l'occasion de dictionner dans le cadre
de cette commission le collectif isolant
la terre contre le CO2 en est membre
fondateurs et en est toujours
aujourd'hui membre actifs pour pouvoir
collaborer le plus de la manière la plus
étroite possible avec les différentes
régions motrices pour pouvoir mettre en
place des politiques ambitieuses de
rénovation énergétique du parc
territorial
nous avons au niveau du collectif et
finir du collectif isolant la terre
contre le CO2 pardon un historique
important d'études
d'expertise technique de contribution au
débat public qui sont toutes disponibles
publiquement sur le site du collectif
isolant la terre contre le CO2 puisque
c'est le mode de fonctionnement du
collectif que de rendre public
l'ensemble des actions menées et donc
toutes ces travaux sont aujourd'hui à
disposition des politiques qu'ils soient
nationaux ou territoriaux pour pouvoir
accélérer la mise en place des plans de
rénovation
au niveau de nos de nos propositions
phares à ce stade du débat outre le fait
que nous sommes des industriels qui
avons subi sur les dernières années des
allers-retours importants conséquents et
destructeurs de valeurs en matière
d'aide à la rénovation énergétique donc
nous appelons évidemment à une à une
constance dans les orientations de
politiques publiques en faveur de la
rénovation énergétique et plus
précisément s'il fallait résumer en
trois grandes propositions les axes vers
lesquels nous souhaiterions à partir de
ces propos liminaires orientés les
discussions nous souhaiterions tout
d'abord
redonner une ambition plus conséquente
au dispositif d'aide à la rénovation
énergétique et en particulier aux deux
dispositifs pierre angulaire de ces
aides à la rénovation que sont le
dispositif ma prime rénov et le
dispositif des C2E
ça a été rappelé au préalablement mais
le dispositif pour commencer par le
dispositif de la prime rénov ce
dispositif qui dispose d'une année sur
l'autre d'environ 2 milliards et demi de
dépenses publiques qui permet d'orienter
sur des travaux de rénovation
énergétique est un dispositif qui dont
le dont l'ampleur est très décalé par
rapport au coût que représente les
mesures de compensation de
l'augmentation forte des prix de
l'énergie que nous subissons que nous
avons subi que nous continuons à subir
lorsque l'on met en regard ces 2
milliards et demi par rapport au coût du
bouclier tarifaire qui de mémoire a été
estimée au moment de son lancement à 44
milliards d'euros sur l'année 2023 et au
coût du des chèques énergie qui en
complément sont estimés à un milliard
d'euros de coadditionnels et donc ces
deux types de dépenses sont des dépenses
certes nécessaires dans cette période
d'inflation importante et d'augmentation
du prix de l'énergie mais ce sont des
dépenses qui ne permettent pas de
préparer l'avenir en matière de
réduction de consommation d'énergie de
réduction de la facture énergétique des
Français et ses dépenses sont à comparer
aux 2 milliards et demi investis dans la
rénovation énergétique grâce à la prime
rénov donc nous appelons évidemment de
nos vœux à une amplification progressive
des investissements dans la rénovation
énergétique via ce dispositif de la
prime rénov
par ailleurs au niveau des certificats
d'économie d'énergie nous subissons en
ce moment même avec le début de la
cinquième période des certificats
d'économie d'énergie un problème de
calage du niveau d'ambition et du niveau
d'obligation de ce dispositif qui a déjà
fait l'objet d'une d'un premier
correctif publié lors du deuxième
semestre 2022 mais se correctif
d'ambition de la cinquième période des
C2E n'est pas suffisant preuve en est
que alors que les prévisions de l'ADEME
lors de l'élaboration de du dispositif
de la 5ème période d'essai de Tablet sur
un objectif de cours de ces deux œufs
supérieurs à entre 8 et 10 euros du
mégawattheure pour les c2os standards et
entre 10 et 14 euros selon les
hypothèses par mégawattheure de ces deux
œufs pour les C2E dédiés au ménage en
précarité énergétique aujourd'hui les
cours de c2os sont très faibles ils sont
aussi bien en C2S standard quand ces
deux œufs précarité inférieure à 8 euros
sont pas en croissance ils sont en
stagnation voire en baisse et le marché
aujourd'hui des C2 heures reste atone en
termes de production de travaux de
rénovation énergétiques ce dispositif ne
joue donc pas son rôle de moteur de
travaux de rénovation énergétique en
complément de ma prime rénov
contrairement à ce qui s'était produit
lors de la fin de la quatrième période
durant une période certes controversée
mais qui avait conduit à une
accélération forte des travaux
d'isolation avec les coups de pouce c2o
de l'époque donc nous appelons dans
cette première partie de mesure
évidemment à redonner une dynamique du
dispositif des C2E au même titre que le
dispositif de ma prime rénov puisque ce
sont deux moteurs significatifs et
extrêmement important pour pouvoir et
complémentaire pour pouvoir
accélérer la structuration des
professions et permettre de massifier la
rénovation énergétique globale et
performante
deuxièmement le deuxième point qui nous
paraît extrêmement important à rappeler
ici et ça a été aussi rappelé par une
partie de mes prédécesseurs on est
aujourd'hui dans une période de
confusion durant laquelle on a plutôt
tendance à travailler sur la
décarbonation qui a travaillé sur la
sobriété énergétique pour le collectif
isolant la terre contre le CO2 vous avez
compris qu'il était selon nous
primordial de travailler en très grande
priorité sur la réduction du besoin en
énergie nous sommes nous répétons à
tue-tête
l'adage que vous connaissez très bien
visant le fait que l'énergie la plus
propre et l'énergie la moins chère et
celle que l'on ne consomme pas et en
premier lieu pour ne pas consommer
d'énergie il s'agit d'isoler que ce soit
les parois opaques les parois vitrées à
ce titre là lorsque l'on sait que isolé
les parois opaques isoler les parois
vitrées et ventiler un bâtiment pour
éviter de des risques de de pathologies
en cas d'amélioration de l'enveloppe ça
représente les deux tiers des gestes de
rénovation énergétique qui sont à
réaliser dans une rénovation globale la
loi climat est résilience précise les
six gestes de travaux à réaliser
isolation des planchers isolation des
murs isolation de la toiture
remplacement des menuiseries mises en
place d'un équipement de ventilation et
remplacement des équipements de
chauffage et de production de jeu de
sanitaires sur ces six gestes le
collectif isolant la terre contre le CO2
est acteur des cinq premiers ces cinq
premiers gestes sont des sont des gestes
de qui sont directement liés à la
sobriété énergétique
nous souhaiterions que ces gestes là
puissent être clairement redynamisée et
priorisé dans les dispositifs d'aide à
la rénovation énergétique que ce soit
dans la prime rénov ou dans les
certificats d'économie d'énergie
et il est bien entendu que ces gestes ne
doivent pas être réalisés de manière
incohérente entre elles nous avons nous
aussi subi les difficultés inhérentes à
des actions de travaux isolés comme les
remplacements simples de fenêtres
l'isolation l'isolation des combles ou
l'isolation des planchers prix de
manière complètement séparée d'un
programme de rénovation globale et nous
souhaitons prendre le contre-pied de ce
qui a été réalisé durant ces dernières
années pour déployer de manière massive
des parcours de rénovation énergétique
performants ces parcours de rénovation
doivent s'appliquer à l'ensemble du parc
existant il comporte 6 gestes comme
préalablement précisé et ces parcours de
rénovation selon notre définition
doivent démarrer systématiquement par
les travaux d'isolation de l'enveloppe
pour tous les bâtiments qui n'en
bénéficient pas
et ensuite lorsque le bâtiment est déjà
préalablement isolé conduire à des
remplacements d'équipements pour aller
vers les équipements les plus
performants du marché et les équipements
des carbonés que sont les pompes à
chaleur et chaudière bois aujourd'hui il
se passe l'inverse dans les dispositifs
publics avec 70% des primes rénov
attribuées à des remplacements
d'équipements comme ça déjà été rappelé
et ça nous paraît à ce stade être
exactement l'inverse de ce que nous
devrions logiquement faire pour pouvoir
atteindre progressivement l'objectif de
donc nous travaillons activement sur ces
parcours de rénovation performants et
c'est parcours auraient vocation selon
nous à devenir les guides de
recommandations des futurs
accompagnateurs Renov et à jalonner
progressivement les étapes de rénovation
en une deux ou trois étapes pour
atteindre la rénovation globale et
obtenir des aides publiques
progressivement au fil de la réalisation
de ces parcours
enfin et pour terminer mon propos nous
sommes au niveau du collectif isolant la
terre contre le CO2
conscient que les mécaniques incitatives
vont progressivement avoir des limites
et le marché doit au-delà de cette
accélération et de cette structure dans
laquelle nous devons nous inscrire en ce
moment le marché doit par lui-même vivre
le marché de la rénovation énergétique
et c'est pour cette raison que nous
sommes favorables à un juste équilibre
entre des mécaniques incitatives et des
mécaniques d'obligations progressives
planifiée pour permettre à chaque
propriétaire occupant à chaque
propriétaire bailleur de s'engager dans
la durée et d'anticiper des travaux de
rénovation donc nous sommes à ce titre
là
nous sommes à ce titre là favorable
au calendrier des gens en place
d'interdictions de mise à la location
progressive des passoires thermiques
puis des différentes classes les plus
dégradées des logements nous aussi
favorable à la mise en place progressive
d'interdictions de mise à la vente dans
la même lignée pour permettre de créer
un signal et permettre aux propriétaires
de s'engager le plus tôt possible dans
les travaux de rénovation en ayant
conscience de l'obsolescence d'une
obsolescence programmée du parc
immobilier dès lors qu'il est énergivore
écoutez je suite à ces différentes
propositions je vous remercie encore de
votre attention et je me tiens
évidemment à votre disposition pour
continuer les échanges autour de vos
questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le porte-parole
donc merci aux gens et aux autres de ces
premières interventions qui sont très
complètes et je laisse la parole sans
plus tarder à notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
tous pour
vos interventions et effectivement très
très détaillées
c'est vrai que dans cette dans cette
commission d'enquête ça nous paraissait
à la fois évident et important de
pouvoir vous additionner parce que on a
vu à la fois les différents ministres en
charge pendant les 10 dernières années
on avait un différents acteurs mais
c'est vrai que du coup d'avoir aussi les
fabricants de matériaux et d'avoir aussi
votre votre retour justement et
notamment en lien avec les politiques
publiques qui sont menées nous
paraissaient
oui évident de toute façon dans cette
dans cette commission donc moi j'avais
j'avais déjà une première question qui
était peut-être à l'ensemble après
chacun répondra comme il le souhaite qui
était peut-être sur sur justement
comment ces politiques publiques ont été
menées on va dire et puis depuis le
Grenelle de l'environnement où là on a
eu des orientations assez fortes
et qui ont évolué puisque aujourd'hui
avec ma prime rénove avec un parcours
qui commence un petit peu un peu plus se
préciser de la manière dont avait été
associée en fait à l'ensemble de ces
orientations c'est réorientations en
tout cas dans les différentes politiques
publiques d'abord est-ce que vous avez
été associé première question et puis
ensuite si c'est le cas de quelle
manière et pour le coup est-ce que bon
vous avez un petit peu répondu mais
est-ce que du coup les orientations vous
vont pour vous dans le dans le bon sens
ensuite j'avais peut-être une question
puisque quand on parle de d'isolation
notamment d'isolation par l'extérieur
on va avoir une table ronde juste après
sur les matériaux biosourcés du coup le
lien que vous pouvez faire du coup entre
vos entreprises et
les types d'isolant les matériaux
biosourcés et puis l'orientation
notamment alors là qui est plutôt dans
le neuf mais avec la R20 qui du coup
prioriser enfin en tout cas plus orienté
sur ce sur des matériaux bio sourcés
donc comment en gros vous vous analysez
ça et vos différentes entreprises se
positionnent par rapport à ça et
notamment en termes d'évolution aussi
enfin je pense que j'avais vu par
exemple que je puisse Isover ou voilà
qui développait un
laine de verre avec des liant des lions
végétaux enfin ou des choses comme ça
est-ce que du coup vous avez enfin voilà
vous travaillez sur ce type d'évolution
et ce type de de transition
et notamment sur puisque c'est vrai que
sur la bon il y a la question de
l'isolation quand on quand on fait face
justement au password thermique mais
après il y a toute la question des
matériaux qu'on va mettre en place de
l'ordre durabilité de leur cycle de vie
de leur impact carbone ça a été dit la
question du recyclage aussi de la
réutilisation etc et de le voir du coup
dans toute la durée pour pas qu'on se
retrouve ensuite avec des matériaux qui
ne seraient ni recyclables ni en tout
cas qui a un impact pour l'environnement
qui puisse être important donc savoir
comment du coup vous travaillez sur sur
ces questions là et du coup ça me fait
un autre question sur la question des
normes et des avis techniques sur le
fait de
par exemple un procédé comme vous avez
montré tout à l'heure pour arriver à ce
qu'il soit vraiment normalisé voilà
comment vous votre avis en tout cas sous
cette sur cette procédure normalisation
et David technique qui me paraît aussi
important alors aussi important pour la
Table Ronde d'après aussi puisque c'est
des matériaux plus plus récents mais je
pense que vous aussi dans dans
l'évolution ça me paraît important de
voir un petit peu comment comment ces
choses là peuvent se mettre peuvent se
mettre en place
et puis et puis et puis si puis une
petite question quand on aura peut-être
d'autres de mes collègues sur le DPE
puisque c'est vrai que bon il y a le DPE
nouvelle formule dont on va voir un
petit peu voilà on attend un petit peu
d'avoir des retours on voit quand même
que c'est un élément important puisque
c'est ce qui va passer ce sur quoi
s'appuie les politiques publiques de
passer en vous disiez à l'interdiction
de de location
si on met une interdiction qui est pas
encore le cas sur la vente en tout cas
l'obligation en tout cas d'isoler sur la
vente on s'appuiera sur le DPE et sur le
classement quoi donc on a quelque chose
qui est assez fort et important et donc
voir un peu votre retour et votre avis
et du coup savoir aussi si vous avez été
associé dans la réalisation et dans les
études sur le DPE et notamment dans sa
seconde formule on va dire
en tant que justement sur les
caractéristiques d'isolation et puis
pour terminer du coup sur la qualité
aussi parce que vous êtes vendeur de
matériaux c'est vrai qu'on a aussi
beaucoup de
ça fabricants et vendeurs de matériaux
mais vous avez on a beaucoup de retour
sur la qualité des travaux c'est à dire
que la réalisation des travaux on a le
pareil de label label RGE toute la
question de la qualification des
entreprises et de faire en sorte que ben
oui c'est très bien de pouvoir isoler un
bâtiment mais encore faut-il que les
travaux soient réalisés correctement
et donc la question du contrôle et de
savoir si justement le fait d'accue une
entreprise soit labellisée suffit ou
est-ce qu'il faudra avoir des contrôles
plus directs en tout cas en fin de
chantier votre avis également sur cet
aspect là voilà merci
un flot de questions
très très précise je sais pas je vous
laisse
comprendre merci madame la Présidente je
veux bien reprendre les quelques points
mentionnés par monsieur le rapporteur
notamment sur notamment sur sur les
contrôles
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
de travaux qui sont effectués par les
entreprises et qui sont des entreprises
de bonne qualité avec des ouvriers
qualifiés et qui exécute de bons travaux
donc les
maîtres d'ouvrages sont vraiment
satisfaits et malheureusement
malheureusement il existe quelques fois
des entreprises qui travaillent un petit
peu moins bien mais n'oublions pas que
95 96 97% des chantiers se passent
correctement
sur les contrôles nous avions eu au
Groupon numéro mentaux une réflexion
notamment lorsque nous avions été
associés aux discussions avec le pôle
national C2E il y a quelques temps sur
justement le laisser deux œufs et nous
avions fait une proposition qui est une
proposition assez simple
vous poser une question personnelle mais
peut-être avez-vous effectué chez vous
des travaux des travaux électriques et
lorsque on remet en cause horlog
lorsqu'on remet en fonction une une
installation électrique vous faites
passer un consuel je vous entends parler
de ça même la présidence
dans nos auditions
mais voilà mais aujourd'hui vous faites
une installation électrique vous faites
des travaux d'électricité chez vous que
vous soyez maître d'ouvrage public ou
privé vous faites 2500 3500 euros de
travaux on vous demande de faire passer
un consuel pour remettre en route
l'installation électrique quand vous
faites une règle une rénovation globale
et performante ou quand vous faites un
geste simple qui dirait un impact sur
votre consommation qui est un certain
montant pourquoi ne pas mettre en place
une filière qui soit un consuel de
rénovation énergétique et qui puisse
permettre d'assurer que les travaux ont
été réalisés de bonne qualité qu'ils
permettent je dirais de d'avoir des
économies d'énergie et une performance
énergétique bien meilleure et on peut
très bien imaginer d'avoir un contrôle
j'irais un an enfin pardon au contraire
juste à la fin des travaux et un an
après la fin des travaux pour contrôler
la consommation la consommation
énergétique donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui je suis très
satisfait au nom de notre association
que ce que cette suggestion soit revenue
parce que je pense que aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui peut véritablement
bien aider et j'irai rassuré tous les
maîtres d'ouvrage et notamment les
maîtres d'ouvrages particuliers qui font
exercer des travaux et quand une
certaine anxiété l'un d'entre nous la
mentionné il y a une anxiété à la
rénovation énergétique qu'est-ce que ça
va donner est-ce que je vais pas me
faire avoir je crois qu'il faut être
très factuel sur ce point-là et je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui peut
rassurer et déclencher faire partie des
déclencheurs cela dont parlait Olivier
servant tout à l'heure je vais juste
parler pour vous est-ce qu'il y a des
blocages aujourd'hui à mettre en place
ce type de contrôle qu'est-ce qui peut
expliquer que pour l'heure on n'est pas
on n'y sont pas arrivés ou en tout cas
que c'est pas été évoqué ou que c'est
pas mis en place déjà je pense que
aujourd'hui il faut simplement qu'il y
ait une filière qui se crée et qui de
l'immobilisation des acteurs peut-être
du peut-être du contrôle peut-être dans
le cadre du DPE je dirais et qu'il y ait
les bureaux de contrôle qu'il y ait des
entreprises qui se mobilisent de façon à
mettre en place ceci on sait le nombre
de travaux de rénovation énergétique qui
apparent donc on doit savoir de façon
mathématique très simplement évaluer les
besoins en main d'oeuvre qui vont faire
ci en faisant un deux trois contrôles
par jour par chantier comme on veut et
on doit arriver à dimensionner une
filière il nous semble nous n'avons pas
été jusqu'à pour être très clair nous
n'avons pas été jusqu'à cette à cette
dimensionnement avec les acteurs donc
quelquefois parler et facile donc voilà
je vais juste après parler de tout ce
qui est resyclabilité et après je je
passerai la parole aux autres
intervenants aujourd'hui en termes de
recyclabilité sur les produits et
notamment les isolants tous les
industriels et toutes les filières
industrielles le film et d'autres
également ont mis en place des processus
de recyclage des produits de
récupération des déchets de chantier et
je vais revenir juste après pour parler
de la Red bâtiment mais
tous les industriels eux-mêmes avant
qu'il y ait une mobilisation de par la
loi Haget avec déjà mis en place des
filières de récupération des déchets et
le fait que aujourd'hui tous les
produits et les isolants que nous
utilisons sont recyclables à l'infini
deuxième point depuis le 1er mai 2023
existe qu'on appelle la responsabilité
élargie du producteur mise en place par
la loi âgée élargi sur les produits de
construction et de matériaux du bâtiment
qui fait que progressivement toutes les
entreprises du bâtiment vont pouvoir et
bien déposer sans frais dans des points
de collecte leur leur déchets de
bâtiment ce qui va permettre de recycler
de façon beaucoup plus efficace les 46
millions de tonnes générées par la
filière annuellement donc là dessus
c'est quelque chose qui est déjà en
place c'est quelque chose qui se fait et
je pense que tous les industriels que
nous sommes ont accueilli favorablement
cette démarche je dirais de la mise en
place de la Red bâtiment par la loi agé
voilà vous avez parlé également mais je
vais laisser les autres intervenir vous
avez parlé également d'inquiétude sur la
pérennité des matériaux utilisés dans
l'isolation j'y reviendrai peut-être
après parce que je pense qu'on a pas les
mêmes espaces de temps ouais j'ai pas de
si quelqu'un d'autre réagir par rapport
aux questions de monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup je
vais je vais je vais compléter ce qui
vient d'être
abordé alors vous posiez la question sur
la partie isolation et
la partie bio de délègues minérale alors
les LED minérale ce sont des produits
à 95% naturels et ensuite effectivement
on a une part qui permet de lier le
produit de faire des panneaux et les
industriels ont fait évoluer c'est par
de liant il y a déjà de nombreuses
années vers des produits biosourcis ils
ont passé de produits plutôt Pétro
sourcés vers des produits biosourcés
donc ça c'est l'aspect R&D de des
industries qui sont dans le dans le
cadre du syndicat et qui sont mis sur le
marché aujourd'hui depuis de nombreuses
années en matière de de recyclabilité
les industriels des laines minérales
proposent au marché depuis plusieurs
années
le recyclage des déchets générés par les
chantiers et des déchets de
déconstruction voilà ça la décision
a été anticipée par rapport à la loi
Haget les industriels n'ont pas attendu
l'expression de la loi pour investir en
la matière et
effectivement nous avons la chance de
nos produits d'avoir un cycle de
recyclabilité complète donc alors la
part il y a deux choses différentes je
j'ai dans mes
liminaires tout à l'heure je vous ai
parlé de contenu recyclés entre 50 et
80% dans ces contenus il y a une part
des laines de verre Hélène de roche qui
reviennent dans les sites industriels et
qui sont réincorporés dans nos process
de fabrication et il y a la part des
matières premières qui viennent d'autres
filières
et qui sont réutilisés dans notre propre
industrie
voilà donc il y a le bio entre
guillemets
et quelque chose de sûrement très bien
mais n'apporte pas toutes les garanties
dans un produit bio c'est une matière
vivante et à ce titre là alors j'en
viens un peu à la question des normes et
des avis technique
quand on parle d'isolant nous avons un
référentiel qui existe depuis près de 50
ans qui s'appelle la cérémie la céramie
est une association qui certifie tous
les matériaux isolants mais sur le
marché c'est une marque une
certification de qualité
elle permet de de fournir à nos clients
quel que soit la typologie de clients la
garantie de la performance alors il y a
un nombre de caractéristiques assez
importantes qui sont certifiées par
tiers indépendants qui viennent
prélever dans nos sites de fabrication
et ses caractéristiques ont une relation
directe avec le caractéristique
alors on va on va certifier la
résistance thermique on va certifier
la compression mécanique parce qu'il
arrive que quelquefois dans certaines
applications en marche sur les produits
sur nos produits on va certifier le
comportement à l'eau aussi des produits
le fait que nos isolants n'absorbent pas
l'eau
lorsque voilà ils sont entreposés à
l'extérieur temporairement lorsqu'ils
sont mis en oeuvre
le en revanche une caractéristique
extrêmement importante quand on parle de
confort et de qualité d'air intérieur
c'est le fait que nos produits soient
perméables à la vapeur d'eau c'est à
dire qu'il va y avoir cette notion de
respirabilité ça c'est fondamental quand
on parle de qualité d'air intérieur et
donc de confort pour les pour les pour
les occupants
donc certification à céramique et
ensuite les avis techniques là c'est une
appréciation globale des produits dans
leur système bon il n'y a pas de
difficulté particulière à ma
connaissance
alors évidemment pour tous les isolants
l'aide minérale manufacturés sont
certifiés sont tous les systèmes sont
détenteurs d'avis technique
les référentiels existent pour j'allais
dire pour toutes les natures d'isolantes
je voudrais revenir sur votre sur vos
propos en matière de durabilité
je représente les isolants l'aide
minérale manufacturées nous sommes très
loin des 25 ans je sais plus quel est la
durée que vous avez mentionnée dans vos
propres linéaires 20 25 alors je vous
rassure
nous sommes l'ensemble des industriels
sont plutôt sur des durées de 40 ans
garantis et nous avons un certain nombre
de cas extrêmement précis qui montrent
que on a des durées de vue qui qui vont
au-delà de 50 60 ans je vais donner un
exemple parce que je l'ai en tête voilà
immédiatement
alors qui n'est pas un exemple en France
vous m'en excuserez madame la Présidente
il y a eu des travaux de rénovation sur
l'aéroport de Copenhague au Danemark et
les isolants qui ont été trouvés
suite à cette rénovation
clairement était proche de leur état
initial voilà et l'aéroport de
Copenhague je crois le les travaux
initiaux étaient de l'ordre de 50 60 ans
donc
pour les isolants je représente il n'y a
pas de problème de durabilité de
pérennité de ces produits alors il faut
savoir qu'il n'y a encore une fois ce
sont des produits naturels avec une part
de lions qui est extrêmement faible
pas d'adjuvant pas d'additifs voilà donc
c'est peut-être ce qui leur confère
cette cette caractéristique extrêmement
importante de durée de vie et de
performance
qui veut prendre la suite
des réponses qui n'auraient pas encore
été prendre la suite alors dans la
lignée de ce que vient d'évoquer madame
Isabelle Bardet je vous confirme que
l'un de nos membres du collectif isolant
la terre a fait des essais de pour aller
mesurer les performances thermiques sur
des bancs équivalents à ceux de la
certification acermique pour des
produits qui avaient été récupérés dans
des combles de maisons individuelles
datant des années 70 et nous n'avons pas
constaté de différence de changements de
performance des produits isolants en
laine de verre de ces produits datant
des années 70 pourtant récupéré il y a
seulement quelques années pour les
réévaluer donc cela confirme ce que
disait madame Bardet sur la pérennité
quant à la pérennité des performances
des solutions d'isolation
minérales
avec dès lors évidemment qu'elles ne
font pas l'objet d'une d'une agression
physique
que ce soit une agression physique
mécanique ou une agression physique liée
à une humidité une trop forte humidité
par exemple donc sur ce point là je
confirme pleinement la
pérennité des performances des solutions
d'isolation bien au-delà des 20 à 25 ans
que vous aviez évoqué tout à l'heure
par ailleurs sur ce sujet des solutions
d'isolation et pour revenir
au sujet de comparaison entre solutions
d'isolation
si l'on regarde un bâtiment existant et
que l'on regarde l'incidence de
l'isolation en matière de décarbonation
on peut très facilement avec l'aide d'un
moteur de calcul comme celui du DPE ou
d'autres moteurs de calcul évaluer le
temps de retour carbone d'une solution
d'isolation si on regarde le la quantité
d'énergie et donc la quantité de CO2
nécessaire pour fabriquer le matériau et
présente au sein des fiches de
déclaration environnementale et
sanitaire
dont parlait tout à l'heure
Jean-Christophe Barban de la imcc et que
l'on compare ce poids carbone des
solutions d'isolation aux émissions de
gaz à effet de serrer vite éviter grâce
aux économies d'énergie générées on
tombe sur un temps de retour carbone de
l'isolation quel que soit les bâtiments
existants qui se situent entre une
semaine et trois mois
donc on a au bout d'une entre une
semaine et trois mois rentabiliser le
poids carbone de la fabrication des
matériaux quels qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient minéraux qu'il soit dérivés du
pétrole qu'il soit biosourcés on les a
rentabilisés d'un point de vue carbone
en moins de 3 mois pour une durée
d'efficacité des travaux qui est de
l'ordre de 40 à 60 ans comme le disait
madame Bardet à l'instant donc lorsque
l'on parle de rénovation énergétique et
d'incidence de cette rénovation
énergétique sur la décarbonation du parc
existant on parle en premier lieu de
d'isolation et d'isolation performante
le sujet du choix du système d'isolant à
une incidence qui est Epsilon sur le
bilan carbone du bâtiment en rénovation
donc ça c'est un point qui est qui me
paraît important à rappeler à ce stade
là et qui est tout à fait vérifiable il
suffit de comparer de prendre les fiches
de déclaration environnementales et
sanitaire et tous les bureaux d'études
ou tous les diagnostiqueurs du marché
pourront vous faire les mêmes calculs
par ailleurs vous posiez la question du
DPM alors de notre côté côté isolant la
terre contre le CO2 nous avons salué
vivement saluer et positivement saluer
les évolutions du DPE qui avait été
pendant un certain nombre d'années un
dispositif en devenir mais
insuffisamment fiable pour devenir
opposable et cette ce dispositif a mis
un certain temps à évoluer pour devenir
un pilier de la politique publique de
rénovation énergétique d'évaluation du
parc et de la rénovation énergétique
c'était une évolution nécessaire qui
s'est fait avec un certain nombre de
difficultés
et force est de constater que le DPE tel
qu'il est actuellement défini comporte
toujours des axes importants
d'amélioration en matière d'évaluation
de performance et de précision de ces
évaluations mais aussi en matière de
formation et d'homogénéité de la
réalisation de ces DPE par les
diagnostiqueurs que vous avez par
ailleurs auditionnés dans le cadre de
cette commission
si on prend le sujet de la méthode de
calcul de l'évaluation des biens
immobiliers cette méthode de calcul est
une méthode relativement sommaire c'est
une méthode d'évaluation qui permet
à la louche j'aurais tendance à dire si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi d'évaluer la
performance énergétique d'un bien sans
pour autant rentrer dans un niveau de
détails suffisant pour discriminer ou
pour différencier des solutions entre
elles
donc ce dispositif est
utilisable pour pouvoir
caractériser les deux extrêmes les
bâtiments à basse consommation d'un côté
classé A et B et les passoires
thermiques de l'autre par contre ce
dispositif
ne s'éloigne à ses fortements des
consommations réelles d'énergie
et ce dispositif est aussi emprunt de
choix a priori méthodologique intégré
dans cette méthode notamment liée au
coefficient de conversion en énergie
primaire liée au coefficient de
conversion en CO2 des énergies et
lorsqu'il s'agit de caractériser des
passoires énergétiques ou des bâtiments
peu performants
on aimait quelques doutes quant à la
capacité de se DPE à être à être à
rendre compte de la réalité d'une
passoire énergétique pourquoi parce que
je ne suis pas persuadé que on est
besoin de faire un calcul et de passer
par un tiers
termitien ou diagnostiqueur pour évaluer
si un mur est isolé ou sur une toiture
est isolée et donc pour notre part côté
collectifs ils auront la terre contre le
CO2 on a beaucoup milité pour que en
complément des classes énergétiques de
la première page du DPE il puisse y
avoir en deuxième page une évaluation du
niveau d'isolation de l'enveloppe qui
est factuel qui est constaté par voie
par parois et qui permet moyennant en
réalisant une moyenne du niveau
d'isolation de caractériser sur une
échelle si le bâtiment est plus ou moins
bien isolé on retrouve ces éléments en
page 2 du DPE et on retrouve par
ailleurs ces éléments liés à la qualité
de l'isolation de l'enveloppe dans les
évolutions en cours du label Bâtiment
Basse Consommation pour lequel le
collectif est énergie à largement
travaillé depuis plusieurs années et on
retrouve dans ces évolutions du label
BBC rénovation une obligation
d'isolation en complément d'une
obligation de performance énergétique et
environnementale global au même titre
que ce que l'on retrouve dans les
bâtiments neufs puisque dans les neuf
lorsque l'on parle de la ro20 on a dans
cette ro-2020 trois grandes parties la
sobriété énergétique avec un coefficient
qui caractérise le besoin en énergie du
bâtiment la consommation d'énergie du
bâtiment c'est deux étant plafonné et
une autre partie liée aux émissions de
carbone et au confort des thés mais on a
bien dans le 9 une obligation de
sobriété énergétique dans l'existence
cette obligation de sobriété elle est
bien plus marquée par la deuxième page
du DPE liée au niveau d'isolation de
l'enveloppe que par la classe
énergétique qui du coup subit les
rendements des équipements subit les
coefficients de conversion divers et
variés qui ont été intégrés
vous posiez par ailleurs la question de
de l'implication dans les dispositifs
d'accompagnement de la rénovation
forcé de constater que
vu les décalages entre nos propositions
aujourd'hui et la réalité de ce qui
s'est passé sur les dernières années
nous avons beau
avoir contribué au débat
le niveau d'écoute a été faible
et
pour illustrer le propos
par exemple j'ai je me souviens de
contribution établie par la imcc et par
un certain nombre de délégataires des
C2A lors de l'élaboration de la 5ème
période de ces deux e lors de
l'élaboration des obligations et un
certain nombre d'alerte liés à la
surproduction des certificats d'économie
d'énergie en fin de quatrième période
qui avait été calculée en février 2021
l'alerte avait été signalée de
différentes manières auprès des porteurs
du projet d'évolution du dispositif des
c2o cette alerte n'avait pas porté ses
fruits ça a conduit à une absence de
prise en compte de cette surproduction
de ces deux œufs de la quatrième période
et à une mise à plat du dispositif lors
du début de la 5e période c'est cette
absence de prise en compte qui a
nécessité un corrective de 600 TT
donc l'équivalent de 4 milliards d'euros
lors de l'été 2022 pour compenser cette
absence de prise en compte donc oui nous
essayons de contribuer
non je ne considère pas que nous ayons
un taux d'écoute ou un taux de reprise
de nos propositions importants pas à la
hauteur de ce que nous aurions pu
imaginer autre exemple sur ce sujet là
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure des parcours
de rénovation énergétique si vous
recherchez dans l'historique les
premiers les premières publications sur
ces parcours de rénovation énergétique
c'est un rapport du chiffre Project qui
a été établi avec par les équipes du
chiffre project en demi-13
avec donc un rapport qui proposait la
mise en place de ces parcours nerveux de
rénovation énergétique cohérent pour
amener vers la rénovation parce
consommation avec des étapes de travaux
ce qu'on vient de se dire exactement la
même chose ce dispositif à ce moment-là
on est un certain nombre à avoir proposé
qui puisse être intégrés dans la
deuxième partie du diagnostic de
performance énergétique à un moment où
le DPE n'était pas en révision à
contretemps
on a avec quelques quelques acteurs du
secteur décidé de créer une association
à ce moment-là liée à qui avait pour
objectif d'expérimenter la mise en place
de ces passeports de rénovation
énergétique l'association expérience p2e
on y retrouvait dans les membres
fondateurs le chiffre Jack le cercle
promodule EDF
Schneider Electric et le groupe
Saint-Gobain ainsi qu'un grand nombre
d'acteurs partenaires dont des
collectivités territoriales qui ont
expérimenté le dispositif durant trois
ans de 2016 à 2019 et les conclusions
étaient produites en 2020 validant le
principe et le fonctionnement correct de
ces passeports de rénovation pour
décrire des parcours et enclencher des
travaux performants cohérent entre ça a
permis de livrer un outil ça a permis de
livrer la déformation pour un certain
nombre de leaders ça a permis de livrer
un guide de bonne pratique et de points
de vigilance en cas de pour la bonne
articulation des travaux de rénovation
au sein d'un parcours et typiquement
c'est aujourd'hui ce type d'action
validé par le terrain validé par la
pratique que l'on souhaite pouvoir
porter dans les évolutions des aides
publiques
très bien alors il nous reste encore
deux intervenants pour
compléter monsieur barbon oui madame le
Président donc simplement d'abord pour
aller tout à fait dans le sens de mes
prédécesseurs sur toutes ces questions
que vous avez posées sur lequel je
dirais pour résumer il y a eu du progrès
mais peu beaucoup mieux faire
globalement que ce soit en termes
d'écoute en termes de d'associations des
industriels à aux politiques publiques
que ce soit dans la mise en place des
outils d'accompagnement dans
le DPE qui a mis du temps à se
stabiliser et qui est encore améliorable
dans les contrôles de la qualité des
travaux ou clairement
la plupart des travaux sont bien
exécutés mais enfin
un nombre de travaux sont aussi
déficients et simplement une
augmentation des moyens de contrôle
permettrait réellement de changer la
donne si on s'en donnait la peine
les labels RGE fonctionnent je dirais
aujourd'hui de manière insuffisante
c'est à dire que au plan technique ils
sont adaptés mais ils sont beaucoup trop
compliqués à mettre en place par les
entreprises artisanales il devrait être
simplifié amplifié pour en faire un
véritable outil de je dirais d'assurance
de la qualité au niveau des travaux
voilà et donc il y a qu'à faire c'est
simplement cela sur la normalisation je
pense que
nous avons la normalisation évolue elle
évolue certes toujours un peu lentement
mais c'est un peu la je dirais normal
lorsqu'on parle de normalisation il faut
s'assurer de la sécurité de la
surabilité des solutions et donc il est
normal qu'il y ait toujours un effet
retard dans l'évolution des normes par
rapport à l'évolution des techniques je
prends un exemple
celui de luciement par exemple le ciment
bacarbonne sont en train d'évoluer
rapidement aujourd'hui il est clair que
de nouvelles normes ont été
introduites pour autoriser des ciment
plus bas carbone dans la construction on
peut certainement aller encore plus loin
mais ça demande réellement vous pouvez
en être conscient il s'agit de la
solidité des ouvrages qu'on voilà que
les experts
fassent un travail sérieux avant
d'entériner de façon définitive telle ou
telle solution technique voilà donc
globalement du programme est peu
beaucoup mieux faire merci
monsieur
d'une manière générale
je vais dans le sens de de mes de mes
confrères et du coup j'en profite pour
remercier de nous de nous écouter
j'espère de que vous pourrez tenir
compte de certaines éléments qu'on a pu
vous vous raconter on est associé on
essaie de rencontrer autant qu'on le
peut les pouvoirs publics pour leur
expliquer on est baigné dans notre
métier tous les jours donc il y a un
certain nombre de choses qu'on sait
qu'on essaie de raconter
et d'une manière générale on nous
objecte souvent oui mais on essaie de
c'est compliqué ce que vous nous
racontez on essaie d'être simple on
essaie d'être lisible vis-à-vis des
vis-à-vis des particuliers vis-à-vis des
personnes qui vont avoir recours assez
dispositifs
et force est de constater que sous
couverte de simplicité on peut tomber
dans certains cas dans du simplisme mais
est passé totalement à côté des sujets
c'est sûr que c'est simple de comprendre
que on peut avoir une subvention en
changeant sa pompe à chaleur mais est-ce
que ça répond véritablement à l'objectif
nous pensons tous que non et c'est pas
parce que dans nos associations nous
n'avons pas de de fabricants de pompe à
chaleur nous travaillons au quotidien
avec ces gens là on a des partenariats
avec ces gens là mais c'est tout
simplement parce qu'on passe qu'on passe
à côté du sujet donc oui ça peut
paraître un petit peu plus complexe de
prime abord mais encore une fois quand
on passe un tout petit peu de temps sur
les parcours dont on a beaucoup parlé on
pense qu'on peut construire des choses
qui qui sont intelligibles et
intendables par partout donc ça pour
nous ça nous paraît fondamental et je
terminerai juste par l'autre l'autre
sujet vous l'aviez dit dans votre
question initiale vous en avez reparlé
sur la notion de de recyclabilité de
réemploi
donc comme ça a été dit l'ensemble de
nos entreprises travaille déjà sur la
neutralité carbone on a tous chacun
d'entre nous ne nous propres agendas sur
les scope 1 2 et 3 donc c'est le sens de
l'histoire et on reviendra pas en
arrière par contre la loi elle a aussi
cet intérêt la mise en place de la Rep
et on l'a vu dans beaucoup de secteurs
d'activité elle va dans un premier temps
elle elle nous oblige nous fabriquant à
des taux de collecte à des taux de
recyclabilité et elle va progressivement
aussi nous nous entraîner sur des sujets
de réemploi qui sont évidemment plus ou
moins complexes selon les matériaux et
les produits dont nous parlons mais qui
seront aussi dans le sens de de
l'histoire donc là la Rep elle va elle
va contribuer à nous faire avancer nous
aussi dans le bon sens voilà
merci alors je sais pas si non oui bien
sûr monsieur
une question complémentaire sur le la
spécificité des
isolants polystyrène comme vous voulez
vous l'avez montré mais c'est
globalement en fait vous en avez très
peu parlé et plutôt vous êtes plutôt
ciblé sur sur les isolants fibreux
et donc voilà du coup avoir aussi votre
votre retour sur ce type de d'isolant
sur à la fois leur
impact impact global mais c'est vrai
qu'on voit aussi je me rappelle quand on
avait travaillé sur la loi GEC pour être
allé visiter un certain nombre
d'entreprises justement sur l'impact
notamment des petites billes plastiques
etc sur le transport sur tout ce que ça
peut faire sur l'impact aussi sur le
chantier de ce type de d'isolant sur
leur peut-être leur durabilité aussi
enfin en tout cas enfin voilà en tout
cas sur ce type de matériau est-ce que
vous aviez voilà des éléments
particuliers à nous transmettre
sur le l'isolant polystyrène je ne
pourrais parler que de l'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur donc pas par
l'intérieur d'accord mais sur
l'isolation thermique par l'extérieur le
polystyrène c'est à peu près entre 78 et
80% des surfaces aujourd'hui réaliser le
marché de l'isolation thermique par
l'extérieur en 2022 c'est 17 millions de
mètres carrés
79% on va dire de d'isolons polystyrène
19% d'isolant laine minérale 2% d'autres
produits
biosourcés notamment
voilà et quelques autres produits
nous avons donc ces
l'isolant qui est aujourd'hui le plus
économique par rapport à d'autres voilà
qui est en train de travailler de façon
très importante sur son poids carbone
pourquoi parce que les fabricants de
matières premières aujourd'hui
travaillent à partir de la biomasse et
sont en train je dirais de développer
des produits que l'on appelle masse
balance pour parler en bon en bon
français il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui au
niveau de la réglementation ces produits
là ne sont pas encore reconnus par la
réglementation française comme
pouvant tracer très exactement
leur part d'énergie verte
ce qui pose un certain nombre de
difficulté c'est à dire que en tant que
consommateur vous achetez chez votre
fournisseur d'énergie de l'électricité
verte vous savez pas combien de pour
cent il y en a ça on l'autorise pour
l'électricité on ne l'autorise pas pour
un isolant comme le polystyrène donc
voilà ça pose des questions il y a une
organisation qui n'est pas présente ici
qui est une association qui regroupe
l'intégralité des fabricants de
polystyrène qui pourraient tout à fait
vous répondre à ce sujet et que vous
pourriez tout à fait rencontrer je peux
pas m'exprimer aujourd'hui on leur nom
mais sur l'isolation thermique par
extérieur voilà quelle est la voilà
quelle est la position durabilité des
produits je dirais 50 ans sans aucun
problème comme les laines comme les
laines minérales aujourd'hui les
premiers les premières maisons isolées
par l'extérieur c'était je dirais plutôt
en Allemagne et en Autriche ça a
commencé en 65 les isolants sont
toujours en place donc alors il s'était
plus fin à l'époque maintenant on les
double donc on fait une sur isolation
mais j'irai il y a aucun problème sur la
sur la durabilité donc voilà donc voilà
sur un petit peu la position j'irai sur
l'isolation thermique par l'extérieur de
notre de l'isolant principal aujourd'hui
dans la dans notre dans notre segment de
marché voilà
alors merci Philippe quelques mots en
complément parce qu'effectivement
l'isolation en polystyrène expansé en
polystyrène extrudé en polyuréthane sont
des systèmes isolation qui s'appliquent
dans différentes typologies de
d'utilisation notamment en mur par
l'extérieur mais pas que donc je vais
vous citer en termes de part de marché
une étude qui est l'étude du cabinet MSI
qui est un cabinet ayant réalisé une
étude sur le et qui réalise cette mise à
jour tous les ans sur la proportion de
solutions d'isolation par type d'ouvrage
en rénovation énergétique et qui
segmente cette étude selon les types de
matériaux isolants et donc en 2022 on
retrouve si l'on prend une répartition
en surface il y a aussi dans cette étude
à répartition volume et je crois même
qu'il a répartition en valeur mais si on
prend la répartition en surface isolée
en 2022 pour des travaux de rénovation
énergétique 58% des surfaces isolées
sont isolées avec des laines minérales
manufacturées
au sein de ces 58% c'est 70% de laine de
verre 30% de laine de roche
lorsque l'on prend les plastiques
alvéolaires qui regroupent des produits
en polystyrène expansé en polystyrène
extrudé et en polyuréthane on a donc une
catégorie qui regroupe 30% des surfaces
isolées en 2022 en rénovation dont 63%
en polystyrène expansé 32% en
polyuréthane 5% en polystyrène extrudé
et on a ensuite donc les produits
d'isolation biosourcés qui en surface
représentent une part de marché de 9%.
le reste étant il reste 3% pour d'autres
solutions diverses et variées
anecdotiques plutôt de du ressort de
l'anecdote sur le marché
est-ce que certaines de nos collègues
qui assistent à l'audition
souhaiteraient poser des questions
Sabines oui Sabine Rexel
j'aurais aimé savoir si vous pensez que
le bâti patrimonial je pense au maison
en temps de bois ou des maisons en
pierre devraient pouvoir bénéficier de
dérogation sur les délais de de
relocation sachant que les techniques
qui sont propres à ce type de bâti nous
semble jusqu'ici insuffisamment connu ou
développé ou même accessible ensuite
j'avais une question aussi à Monsieur
Bousmar vous nous disiez que 95% des
entreprises d'isolation extérieure sont
membres de murs mentaux
des industriels des industriels
industriels pas des entreprises de pause
des industriels j'aurais aimé savoir qui
sont les cinq autres pour cent
je peux donner des noms si vous voulez
mais en fait il y a quelques industriels
qui ne souhaitent pas qui ne sont
quelquefois des industriels qui ne sont
pas français en fait qui ne souhaitent
pas adhérer et qui importe en France des
produits et qui ne souhaitent pas en
fait adhérer à notre association voilà
c'est juste ça
voilà alors donc j'ai ma question par
rapport au bâti patrimonial
alors je vais
je vais répondre à votre question madame
depuis une dizaine d'années il y a
beaucoup de travaux à l'échelle
territoriale pour cartographier les
différents types de bâtis historiques
qui sont souvent régionalisées avec des
modes constructifs régionalisés et pour
pouvoir faire en sorte d'adapter des
combinaisons de solutions parce qu'il
s'agit pas de choisir un produit mais
bien une un système qui peut être par
exemple un système d'isolation de mur
par l'intérieur par l'extérieur avec
donc des combinaisons de solutions qui
sont à adapter au cas par cas au bâti
anciens et en particulier pour pouvoir
tenir compte des propriétés à la fois
mécaniques et de l'incidence des
propriétés hygroscopiques sur la
mécanique de la façade de la structure
et donc il y a aujourd'hui des guides
qui ont été élaborés des solutions
techniques articulées qui existent qui
sont peu connus insuffisamment connus et
ses guides ces solutions on en trouve
pour chacune des régions quasiment et
ses adaptations de solutions au bâti
local mérite d'être largement déployés
sous forme de formation aux entreprises
pour faire en sorte que les entreprises
et le réflexe du choix de la juste
solution pour éviter par exemple de
créer des pathologies qui pourraient
être liées par exemple à l'utilisation
de matériaux qui
confineraient l'humidité dans la façade
avec des façades qui par exemple
auraient des propriétés mécaniques qui
se détérioreraient en présence d'une
forte humidité ou à l'inverse on a aussi
des types de façades anciennes dont les
propriétés mécaniques se détériorent
quand la façade est trop sèche donc on
peut avoir les deux phénomènes dans un
sens comme dans l'autre c'est pour ça
qu'il faut regarder au cas par cas et
que ces travaux d'adaptation des
solutions à ma connaissance ont été
faits pour je pense l'intégralité des
types de bâti existants mais on constate
un vrai manque de déploiement de ces
solutions de diffusion sous forme de
formation locale aux entreprises pour
pour que le geste le réflexe de choix de
la solution soit le bon et que l'on
puisse de manière sereine déployer des
travaux de rénovation énergétique sans
risquer des pathologies diverses et
variées
moi je voudrais simplement aucun d'entre
vous n'a parlé d'un risque éventuel ou
pas de pénurie de matériaux
ce que vous pouvez nous rassurer
là-dessus
donc je crois que enfin avoir dit au
démarrage que de manière générale il n'y
avait pas de risque perceptible de ce
point de vue là donc il peut y avoir des
situations ponctuelles
pour d'autres raisons mais a priori les
industriels ont les capacités de suivre
les besoins en matériaux dans le cadre
des objectifs qui ont été fixés
vous avez dit aussi que donc en termes
de filière il y avait tout à fait une
capacité aujourd'hui à pouvoir répondre
à une demande dans le cas où bien
évidemment on souhaite cette
massification tout en termes de
qualifications que de
manière générale les qualifications
enfin mes collègues pourront pourront
valider mais les qualifications sont là
bien entendu les besoins de main
d'oeuvre sont soucis constants c'est pas
propre à notre industrie à nos
industries mais c'est clair que les
moyens sont là il peut y avoir pour un
certain nombre de produits importés mais
qui encore une fois sont une minorité
dans nos domaines pour des raisons très
très conjoncturelles des manques
ponctuels mais je dirais que ce n'est
pas en tout cas c'est pas un sujet sur
lesquels on est aujourd'hui inquiet
titre du groupement du mur mentaux
l'intégralité des détenteurs de systèmes
d'avis techniques
d'isolation thermique par extérieur
dispose de centre de formation certifié
qui toutes les semaines sont quasiment
plein parce que ils forment des
compagnons des ouvriers
toutes ces détenteurs de systèmes
d'isolation thermique par l'extérieur
interviennent également dans des centres
de formation pour apprentis
interviennent dans des lycées
professionnels il y a des syndicats
professionnels aussi qui essayent de
rendre les métiers de l'isolation
thermique clarisseur plus attractif
voilà parce que il faut être clair aussi
dans les métiers du bâtiment nous avons
un certain nombre de personnes qui
partent à la retraite et qui est
certainement plus d'ouvriers qui partent
à la retraite aujourd'hui que de jeunes
qui ne veulent lire entrer d'accord ces
petites choses que nous avons tous sur
nous ils sont aussi certainement pour
quelque chose voilà donc mais il y a
tout un effort aujourd'hui qui est fait
par tous les industriels de l'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur et l'eau des
d'autres
syndicats ici présents ont les j'imagine
les mêmes démarches
je crois que vous vouliez aussi
intervenir là-dessus oui je vous l'avais
confirmé dans les propos liminaires
j'allais même dire que à l'heure
actuelle les
industriels d'Hélène minérale sont
plutôt dans une période à gérer les
arrêts techniques de ligne de production
pour deux raisons essentielles le marché
du neuf on l'a évoqué le marché de la
construction neuve est en baisse
conséquente et
les évolutions
de type Stop and Go sur les aides à la
rénovation énergétique c'est quand même
plutôt ça que nous nous notre vécu
depuis un an et demi deux ans que que le
manque de capacité et je vous l'ai dit
les industriels des laines minérales
continuent d'investir en sur leur
capacités donc il n'y a pas de il n'y a
pas de sujet de de pénurie si les
décisions
étaient amenées à
véritablement relancer l'isolation dans
les énergétique voilà et avoir un peu
plus de stabilité oui c'est important
vous imaginez que voilà quand on arrête
des portions de ligne ou que voilà on
s'isolalise la production sur la semaine
sur le mois ça a des conséquences
extrêmement importantes pour nos
industries
bien écoutez sauf si l'un d'entre vous
aurait quelque chose à rajouter que nous
n'aurions pas évoqué dans nos propos
respectifs
et ben voilà et bien écoutez on vous
remercie très sincèrement d'avoir
participé à cette table ronde c'est très
intéressant bonne continuation merci